CHARLES WAS TOTALLY
UNINTIMIDATED ALL THE WAY
THROUGH, BRAVE AND CLEAR
THINKING TO THE END.
WHAT A MAN.
TONIGHT WE WANT TO TALK TO SOME
OF THE PEOPLE THAT KNEW HIM BEST
HERE AT FOX, STARTING WITH HIS
FRIEND OF MANY YEARS, BRIT HUME,
WHO JOINS US TONIGHT.
BRIT, PEOPLE LEFT
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER, EVEN THOSE
WHO DISAGREED WITH HIM.
WHAT WAS IT ABOUT HIM THAT THEY
WERE RESPONDING TO?
>> IT WAS A RARE COMBINATION,
TUCKER, AND THE SENSE THAT HE
HAD THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECT
HAD THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECA
HAD THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECD
HAD THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECO
HAD THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECE
HAD THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECT
HAD THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECA
HAD THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECL
HAD THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECO
HAD THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECF
HAD THIS EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECA
SORT OF ADMIRED AND NONE OF US
REALIZED -- NONE OF US THOUGHT
WE COULD EVER COME CLOSE TO
EQUALING.
HE WAS LITERALLY IN A CLASS BY
HIMSELF.
HE WAS ONE OF A ONE-OF-A-KIND.
AND ON TOP OF THAT, HE HAD COME
UP FOR ALL OF THE SHARPNESS OF
HIS THOUGHT AND WRITING AND --
HE WAS EXTRAORDINARILY KIND AND
GENTLE.
AND THE COMBINATION MADE YOU
LOVE HIM, AND WE DID, ALL OF US
DID.
THE AUDIENCE DID.
YOU COULDN'T HELP IT.
YOU THINK ABOUT WERE DOING
TONIGHT, TUCKER, WE ARE ALL
FEELING SAD AND SORRY, BUT WE'VE
BEEN ON THE AIR SINCE 6:00 WHEN
THIS NEWS BROKE, AND WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THIS ONE SUBJECT.
AND, YOU KNOW, YOU MIGHT SAY,
THAT'S BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, HE WAS
ON FOX IF HE WAS THEIR GUY.
YEAH, THAT'S TRUE.
BUT HE WAS A GIANT OF OUR TIME
AND ALL OF OUR TRADE, AND HE
CARRIED IT OUT TO THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS.
HE WROTE BEAUTIFULLY.
HE WAS CAREFUL ABOUT HIS FACTS.
HE THOUGHT THINGS THROUGH.
AND HE CONDUCTED HIMSELF WITH
EXTRAORDINARY DIGNITY AND GRACE
AND WE COULD ALL SEE IT AND CAN
ONLY ASPIRE TO IT.
>> Tucker: NO BITTERNESS, PURE
HUMANITY.
HIS INSTINCTS WERE SO
RELENTLESSLY DECENT.
I DON'T THINK I KNEW ANYONE WHO
DISLIKED HIM.
>> NO.
I KNOW PEOPLE WHO DISAGREED WITH
HIM, AND THEY WERE SOMETIMES
ANNOYED OR OFFENDED BY, YOU
KNOW, THE SHARPNESS WITH WHICH
HE WROTE, PEOPLE WHO WERE NOT AS
SYMPATHETIC TO ISRAEL AS CHARLES
UNFAILINGLY WAS.
BUT ON A PERSONAL LEVEL, IF YOU
EVER SAW HIM OR WATCHED HIM, YOU
COULDN'T -- YOU COULDN'T DISLIKE
HIM.
YOU COULDN'T HELP BUT ADMIRE
HIM, EVEN IF YOU DISAGREED WITH
HIM, YOU RECOGNIZE THE POWER IN
US OF HIS THOUGHT, THE
THOROUGHNESS OF HIS RESEARCH,
AND THE QUALITY OF HIS WRITING,
AND THE COMBINATION WAS STRONG.
IF YOU KNOW HIM PERSONALLY, THAT
WONDERFUL QUALITY HE HAD, THAT
KINDNESS, GENTLENESS, GRACE.
IF YOU KNOW WHAT HE HAD BEEN
THROUGH, YOU SAW THE WAY HE
HANDLED ALL THAT, YOU ADMIRED
HIM AS HE PROBABLY DIDN'T ADMIRE
ANYONE ELSE.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYONE THAT I
ADMIRED MORE THAN I ADMIRED
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER AND DO TO
THIS DAY.
>> Tucker: A SPEAK FOR SO MANY